[Music]
how's it going with my name and be
rampant and welcome to where I sit
married yes that is place Asian what you
can't drill your PlayStation what flex
tree what you can't drill your
PlayStation what you can't clear you
can't grill your PlayStation while
playing video games well you don't know
how to live welcome to yeah been a
little stressful lately so we're just
setting chilling and my where I added
videos pretty much and well good we're
gonna open a bunch of these old things
and it's gonna be awesome it's all iced
diet I don't know about you bros but I
always want to open the big ones first
this and I think I think you bros
realize that too because a lot of times
I get these big packages and there's
like this little thing inside and it's
like you disappoint me I'm just kidding
I love all
it looks like I have to use my opener I
really enjoy your video so I decided to
give you a get ah you really you really
shouldn't but this carpet can use for
anything I made just for you there's a
little surprise in the cockpit keep
doing videos love you know and broke
roughest - you know and I do not expect
the carpet I'd be lying if I say I
expected a car
haha maybe I missed the chair in math
and nice surprise I guess I can also
wear it as a hat
alright next package what you never wear
carpets as hat well in Sweden we wear
carpets as hat don't don't worry about
it time to get my duffle stop working my
spatula I tried my badass spatula oh
yeah ha ha ha ha oh no he lost his sword
man what the hell are you doing you
idiot Delaney ok that's awesome
Thank You Beth thank you that big
there's awesome awesome fan art I got
that we got I'm a dolphin all right cool
I always wanted to be a dolphin
[Music]
okay that's the best fun all right
another package huh why don't we having
here cool I like her she draws all right
si sent all right these are really cool
and slender Murr and a bra they're
really cool see that krispity krunch bro
bites you and you bite the brow and the
bro bye - bye oh that's so sweet
not it's all sweet sends me the best
drawing that he or she did I think
that's pretty cute that's really nice I
love to be and then dirty hey I love
guerrillas I really get oh ha ha
you got the [ __ ] back that's awesome
yeah and whatever have over here we got
a legend on the backside I don't know
what's up tonight Wow the most awesome
best barrel ass-kicker hair chair mode
activate the Reuben kill her
Ruby's mom's killer that's a terrible
cutie pie I lost it
Thank You Brad what else we got a
picture of a breakfast alright I gotta
show this enjoy that
oh you're full handwriting finally I
made with sin yo male I've been waiting
for long for this moment I need to sorry
if I spend your life with do you have a
P Leo back there alright so this is for
a cutie pie as well from Maddie and
berry the other one is for me and it's
an awesome drawing of me playing slender
[ __ ] slender I'm so glad I finished that
game
alright it's awesome Thank You Mandy and
baby alright it's a diaper
I guess Hayley did for you PD care more
active Ark awesome and then inside we
have search yet it's a little piggy I'm
pump yeah yeah I am now and Land of
Lincoln members because it sounds like I
don't know why and then brofist Jonna
thank you and this is an awesome
painting of pit fire I love her he or
she draws the fauna and me hell yeah
it's from Stephanie I press I'm gonna
end it here but thank thank you so much
for all the mail and all the creative
stuff that you make
you really appreciate it you taking the
time and money I ever did anything you
bros do really thank you all so much for
all your support it's really what makes
videos fun for me and you know what and
you know it's time for the breakfast all
right you ready down
[Music]